this elephant is the latest to be killed
in the state of assam
she was electrocuted by a live wire
fence
put up by villagers trying to keep the
animals away from their homes
saraswati and her family live close to
where the pregnant elephant was found
dead they deny erecting illegal fences
but say the wild elephants wreak havoc
on their lives
they destroy houses chase people destroy
the fencing there was one day that we
couldn't even stay here because they
destroyed the house
we had to flee to someone else's house
elsewhere in chiarang district farmer
dhananjay surveys the damage to his
crops
i had a good crop and look what's
happened there is a forest nearby
and the elephants are creating problems
every day we don't sleep at night
we spend our nights in the field
guarding the crop
if we fall asleep inside for an hour or
two
and come outside in the morning the
crops are destroyed
wildlife officials say the loss of
natural habitat is leading to more
elephants
leaving the forests and more deaths of
both the animals and villages
as they come into contact with each
other human population is increasing day
by day
but the superiority we are losing the
land where the
while animals go they are losing the
habitat every day
but villagers in the district of nagao
believe they may have found a solution
they've set aside 33 hectares of land
for the elephants
and have created what they call a meal
zone for them
and they say since growing rice for the
elephants the animals have left their
crops alone
for the last two years elephants are
giving us love and we are giving them
love back they don't come to the village
often anymore and when they do
they just pass by quietly they don't
harm anything that is why we are
thankful to them
wildlife officials say creating meal
zones isn't a permanent solution because
they lure elephants out of their natural
habitat
but the villagers of nagao say they've
found a way to live in harmony with the
animals
for now elizabeth piranha al jazeera new
delhi